Very good afternoon, Brenda. How is it doing?
I'm well, how are you?
Debra.
I'm doing good as well. Thank you for asking.
Doing.
Thank you.
And are we expecting Brandon to be here as well?
He will probably be joining late. It looks like he was in a prior meeting. It looks like it's running over a little bit, so.
Okay, no worries. And also, Manish, he has some family emergency, Brenda. His mother was not doing well. So he just left for the home. Yeah, he's just left for the home. So that is why you see me and Kavan on the call. I'm not sure if you have meet, if you have seen Kavan earlier.
Ohh.
She knows me. She knows me.
Oh, yes, yes, many, many meanings, many meanings, yes.
Yeah.
It's just like that because we never came on a call together, Kawandeep. Maybe it was either you or me every time. It's the first time that we are on the call.
The.
Oh, okay, maybe so. All right, I was gonna say I know I've met with both of you before, so okay.
Okay, so that is the reason Manish is not in, but yes, our deck is ready and we can talk about performance, your concerns about those engineers. So I think in the meantime, you're just waiting for Brent and we can start. Brenda, if that works for you.
Yeah, we can give like a minute or two and then just probably go ahead and start. He said he would just, he would probably join late, so that's fine. We'll give it a meeting just a minute, just cushion. A matter of fact, I was just finished it. I just finished up my one on one this month with Alice, so I'm still putting notes in for that.
That.
I have to say it went well. It went well. I've encouraged her to not just to wait for one on one, you know, if there's something, you know, if something goes on, it doesn't matter what with the ticket or with anything, just to just to let me know.
Yeah.
Okay.
You are just reading my mind, Brenda. When is your one on one schedule for Hazel?
The.
Let me check my calendar. Actually, I'm in Team GPS now, I can tell you. Hazel's is scheduled for May 26th.
Yeah.
Okay.
Okay, get that. Thank you so much. And I'm...
May 26th, 99 Central, so.
Okay, and trust me, I have been teasing Hazel like, whenever you have any problem, don't wait for your one on one. It should be like, you know, reach out to Brenda any point of time and I'm encouraging her and Manish as well. But please go ahead and set up a call with Brenda. You just need to, you know.
Yeah.
Ask where she's struggling. Let let us know from Brenda as well. Those all things over there, so.
And I told, yeah, I did. I told Hazel that, but I'm going to tell her again. So, yeah, just let me know.
Now, we are going to talk about that. We are going to talk about these all pointers when we are presenting the deck today, okay? Because I received, you know, that neutral survey from your side, which is fair enough. If you feel that there is still a scope of improvement and if he has to do something more, I definitely want to make a plan around that.
And I really want to make sure that next time when I get something, any of those he said that should be green color, not ember anymore, but yes, for that I need, I need to, you know, buy your happiness, so...
Okay.
Ha ha ha.
Up.
You know, I'm a people pleaser. So I have a tendency, I've always had a tendency just to put green, you know, because it's almost a personal thing. I don't want it to seem like I don't like somebody, right? But I then, you know, the more I did this job as a manager, it's like, I think I need to give that feedback.
So.
though, or you, because that's what I want to see, right? Because you're not going to know. Yeah, you're not going to know what I'm feeling unless I tell you, right? So.
Yeah.
And, and you, and your feedback is very accepted. Your feedback is very accepted.
True. I always say one thing, I always say one thing, Brenda, that you know, people manager and people management is a very thankless job. It is just like, you know, a goalkeeper, you save 9 goals, nobody talks about it, you miss one, people start talking about it, right? So I, yeah, and trust me.
Yeah.
Exactly. That's exactly right.
I'm not, you can say that, you know, really sad of these neutral service because they give you the real picture. Now it has to be a fair reflection how Brenda feels about Hazel. And that is what I really, now I want to work on a plan. Now I want to ensure when I say that I need the green color, not to put any pressure on you or on Manish.
Right.
Yeah.
Right, right.
But I really, really need to, you know, work this girl in a right way and to align her according to your expectation. That is very important, you know, because these three people are not working for ITBD, but they are working for turnkey, right? That is how I feel. I think it's 1235. Let's start, and I'm pretty sure Brenda can join us.
Mhm.
Yeah.
Mmh.
Okay, yeah.
whenever he gets the opportunity. Thank you so much, Brenda. If I have your blessings, Kavan, if you can just go ahead, share your deck.
Okay, sounds good.
Yeah, sure, so give me.
Thank you so much.
Ten seconds, what 10 seconds is.
Just need two seconds and you should be able to...
The.
Take a time.
Thank you so much. So again, welcome to the call, Brenda. We are just going to talk about the May 26th monthly business review. I always call it a strategic business review that I do with my partners. Go to next. So going to talk about the agenda. We are going to talk about the highlights. I want to share.
a service improvement plan that I, you know, we have created for Hazel that is going to be the talk point, major talk points for this call. Talking with the highlights, Ellice, she has handled the dispatch for five days. And there was one connect with Brandon where he did mention that, you know, this is a part of the plan where you want to ensure that somebody is ready.
whenever there is a requirement to handle dispatch on emergency basis. So Alice has been working and trained on that part. Along with that, good part is that she has completed the security audit training. If I talk about Hazel, she has reviewed the backup sheets and backup status. This is a regular to do, regular part of her daily job she's doing on it.
Yes.
Along with that, she's the one who is working on the backup optimizations or cleaner process in ASIN portal as well. And I want to ensure you that she's working independently over there. But again, a part of the improvement plan that I'm going to cover over there. If I talk about Derek, he continues to be a rockstar for this account. Unfortunately, he's just battling with a bad health right now. He was not in for two days.
But he has completed Wash Guard and Fortunate vulnerabilities. He worked on those things. And then he completed cyber QP and DMARC training. So that is the highlight for Derek for me. Great, thank you. Moving to the next one, which is this Hazel service improvement plan. And primarily, I'm going to talk about that, you know, because I definitely want
Yeah.
Yes.
hard to work has put expectations and I want Hazel and you be on the same page. So these are the major issues that we identified. I think Evan you did mention that to Manish during the one-on-one conversations, that frequent time sheet issues, they were identified for Hazel during April.
Okay.
Second was that, you know...
You feel that still there is too much dependency on Derek for completion of backup and patching responsibilities, lack of confidence and ability to work independently. Lack of confidence, I agree with you. I have been working very closely with this girl, Hazel, and now earlier I was doing...
more kind of mentorship now Manish who is doing it. She looks confident when she talks to it.
And Vishal, we're like really friendly people, so I don't know. At least we're not that intimidating. Like, we're really not. We're Americans in the South. We're pretty friendly, you know, like.
No, no, no, no, no, not, not, not at all, not at all. We just, you know, because earlier.
Earlier what happened, earlier what happened, she was a part of a backup team who was working absolutely in backup. There was hardly any interaction. She was using those tools, test, you know, and then we have a separate team who was handling client issues and who was going on a client calls and everything. So that is where she has been working on those things. So she's someone who likes to.
Mhm.
quickly complete her stuff and then go. She's not someone who is able to showcase what exactly she has been doing and able to talk about her work that frequently. So that is where when I say that in lack of confidence and we're just trying to, we're just pushing her to just come out of your comfort zone, start talking about your work. If you have done something, start talking about it, right?
Right.
In particular, if I talk about the first one, frequent time sheet issues over there, how to eliminate recurring time sheet errors over there. Manish has reviewed her sheet and he ensured me that this has been resolved for a major extent. However, he's still working to, you know, he's still continue to work or review her worksheet.
regular basis to make sure you don't see those errors anymore. And this is something he's doing it on daily basis. Just connect with Hazel that hey, do you see any problem when you're making those time entries? Then the code you need to choose, make sure you're choosing the right code over there.
Okay.
Okay. And also, this is not just, this is, this is other technicians that are here as well. This is, you know, this is not an out of the ordinary issue, I guess I would say. You know, this is, this is ongoing with a lot of folks. So.
That is, that is the first thing, yeah.
Yeah, Manish, Manish was telling me about that as well. But here, because primarily we were talking about Hazel, I really wanted him to put more focus on Hazel. And then dependency on Derek to complete the backup. Again, let me assure you, this girl is doing most of the tasks independently. And now to gain more.
Right.
Mm.
Uh-huh.
where at least from 4 to 630, she will be alone in the shift. She will be able to handle those all tasks independently on her, like what Denise was doing earlier. Because right now she's in the same shift. Yeah.
Right, but we never got Denise to the shift we wanted. We want like a 2 A.m. central to, we want the old shift, the one that Avery and all have, but we've never been able to pull it back up where they were working from 2 A.m. till, was it 2 to?
So...
Two, OK.
Two to 10, 2 to 11. That's our main goal. That's how we had it before with Barrett and Avery. Yeah, yeah. Okay.
Okay.
I can, I can check that. I can check that internally. When you say 2 A.m. that is going to be 3 A.m. E.T. And Kavan, if you can just take a note of that, and I think that will be that will be a to-do for us.
Yeah.
That's eventually where we want to move. Yeah, that's what we kind of eventually want to do. But, you know, like I said, Avery had it first and then Varick, and then after Varick, I think it was kind of a training issue, like back and forth, you know, so, but that's the original time shift. We've just never been able to get back.
To that.
I understand that. So you are saying 2 A.m. CST to that is going to be like 11 A.m. CST, right? 2 to 11. So that is 3 to 12. Okay.
Yes.
Yes. Yes. Yeah. And the reason I pushed it, actually it used to be 130, but the reason I pushed it to two is because the meetings that we have scheduled to go over the backups and everything once a week, that occurs at 10. And it's a 30 minute meeting. And you know how things go.
Go, you know how meetings sometimes go over a few minutes or something. I don't want to, I don't want that the engineer to be, you know, stuck. It is at on every Wednesday at 10 A.m.
Yep.
What is the meeting time in, I mean?
It's a it's a everyday meeting.
No, just every Wednesday weekly at 10 AM. Yes.
Wednesday, 10 A.m. Wednesday.
Okay, no worries. I think we can see the possibilities over there. I need to check with Max or Manish on that. Even I'm not very, very, very sure about it. But I can double check with him and if there will be a possibility, because I know this girl is handling those things independently, especially if I talk about backup she's doing that. I'm pretty much confident that we can move her in an independent ship. So I...
Okay.
Mhm.
I'll just check that. That is a to-do that I need to come back to you. Confidence, we are already working on that. Once we align her in the independent shift, I'm pretty sure that will be visible to everyone. After that, if there will be a scope of improvement, then we will continue to work on that from our side. Okay, that's great. We'll keep you posted on that progress.
Okay.
I want to keep a weekly check-up, a weekly, you know, a kindness over there, not more than 10 minutes, Brenda, only 10 minutes call to just figure it out that, hey, how's Hazel performance and how do you feel about Hazel work? I want Manish to have that connect with you. I'll let him to talk to you because he's not here right now. So he can just ask for your availability because you are really busy throughout the day. I don't want to bother you.
Do that, hey, are you available for a Quick Connect? I want to have a...
in white over there so that you know that this is only 10 minutes call in. If it is possible, I want to, you know, not every time, but sometime I want to include Hazel over there so that, you know, me or Max and you and Hazel can connect together and let her ask, let her see that if she needs any help from us.
as a group, as a team.
OK, alright.
Right, that is that is what my intent is, so I'll ask Max to find some time in your calendar and then we can just go through that. OK, yep, that's all I have for Hazel plan that I'm just putting in place over there. One more thing, one more update. So I spoke to Brandon, I think it was last week.
Because right now, LS is doing 8 to 5. And I know this is not an ideal time zone for you because this is going to be like 9 to 4, right? No, she's doing 8 to 5 ET, CST for you right now. Whether we want her, no, she's doing 9 to 6 CST. I'm sorry, I'm really confused with the time zone.
She's doing 9 to 6 and we want her 8 to 5, correct?
Correct.
Right. So just right now, because she's living in an area where transport was not really possible, we had a lot of lots of struggle with with the transport team, internal transport team to arrange something over there. And then it is because right now she's staying in Delhi, NCR area, where exactly she stays. There was there was a security issue as well.
Ah.
Hey.
over there. So there were lots of back and forth conversation with transport team over there. I informed Brandon over there. I took his approval that, you know, instead of keeping her...
Right now she's doing 7 to 4, right? CST.
Yes.
Right. So I told him that instead of seven to four, because then we are losing last one hour and then in one hour she doesn't have much to do. Can I can she do can she does 830 to 530 CST? And Brandon was pleasant with that. He was happy with that. Okay, we can pull her in 830 to 530.
I'm fine with that. Yeah, no, that's fine. Yeah.
Yeah, that's right. So that is, that has been a solution that I got it, that instead of a 7 to 4 where I do not see her productivity, so first start doing 830 to 530 at least we, she will stay in those business hours and she will add more value to your account. And I'm pretty certain this stands complete.
And by coming Monday, we should be able to make that change. So again, yeah, again, Manish will do more communication on that, but I'm 99% positive this stands complete for us.
Okay, that sounds good.
Okay, that sounds great.
Great, thank you so much. That's all I have from operations standpoint. If you just go next, Kavan, yeah, we are going to talk about the performance analysis over there. I'll quickly go through that and let me know if you have any question for us talking with the Derek one. So total utilization, 77% that stands at billable one. Non-billable is 23%.
Sure.
He took one half PTO, half PTO that was taken on April 24th. But apart from that, then you can see the breakdown for every week. But this guy is really, really doing good. Along with the mentorship role, he's doing a great work with that. If I talk about Hazel.
Billable versus non-available, that is 74% versus 26%. Primarily the reason is that she took four days PTUs over there. One more thing, did I tell you Derek has, we are going to level up his designation in ITBD. He cleared our internal assessment.
No.
Uh-huh.
And this guy is becoming, you know, continues to be the valuable asset. He was very happy and we are going to level up his designation. He cleared the internal assessment, so he's level up with us right now. So that is that is a good news. Yeah, thank you. Yes, I will. I will definitely pass your. Yep.
Oh, that's great. That's great.
When we had our one on one, he was very happy with the training and the things that he's doing now. So I hope that that's like helped, you know, and, you know, I mean, we always want to see everybody grow, right? And if we're, and if we're a part of that, then that's a wonderful thing, you know, so.
Yes.
Trust me, I'm not trying to please you, or whenever I talk to, especially when I talk to, when I talk to Derek, he's all gag about your about your support, and I am, and trust me, I always give example of this partnership whenever I'm talking internally, when I'm talking to the internal other groups, like Vaid Finance, with ADMIN, with our management team, I always talk about turnkey, and it's not just me.
No.
Mhm.
Ah.
It's Manish who is talking about turnkey, it's Natalie who is talking about turnkey, that when we talk about partnership, this is what exactly we mean. So thank you so much for all the continuous support and partnership that, you know, we have made throughout these years. And it was not possible without yours, without Brandon support. So I really appreciate that.
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, you're welcome. We're happy to, we're happy to be involved with anything like that, an improvement of anyone's technical skills. I mean, it helps us, it helps you, it helps, it helps the technician. So that's what, that's what it's about, right? So.
Yes.
I...
Yeah, absolutely. Thank you so much again. Sorry, I continue to distract because normally I'm not the one who is presenting the deck, so I continue to talk about. Yeah, talking about the utilization, Elish is, she's the topper. 85% is the billable one. No challenge with Elish since she's back and she's enjoying her married life. I think that is.
Das.
You did fine, it's fine.
boosting her to do well in professional life as well. So she continues to do well. Just in the morning, she got that review, 10 out of 10 CSAT from client. So that was good. And happy to see that. Thank you so much. Next one again, this is the, yeah, this is a ticket resolve rate.
Yeah.
Yes.
That is more than 80%, target is 70%. So total ticket resolved 214, closed 170, worked 214, my bad. And then the breakdown week-wise we have that is for Elise. Here we are talking about Derek. Guy continues to be a rockstar. 89% is the ticket resolve rate.
Sort of 178 ticket, he's worked up on 158, he was able to resolve.
Okay.
Yep, and Hazel, 65% is the resolve rate for her. And ticket work two to three, ticket close 145.
To be honest, I have not gone through the details on this, that you know, if she is, yeah.
You know what? I don't even know if that's accurate as far as, because it may be that she, it may wind up being like that because she's just leaving the ticket open to, you know, to analyze it through the week or something. So I don't, I think she's probably higher than that, like in real time. I mean, the ticket that may, that may show something else.
I was just talking about that, yeah.
Yes.
That is, yeah.
See, you know what I remember, so...
Yeah, that is why I want her to connect every week with you because it's not me who can boost her confidence. It's always going to be you. Trust me, that is what we did with Ellie says, well, if you remember last year, she was always saying that, okay, I'm not very sure if I do this, what will be feedback from Brenda if she's going to say something.
She was always trying to please you. And I'm pretty sure that is the case with Hazel as well. But I'm sure a weekly call will definitely help on that front.
Y'all, I'm not that scary, I promise. I'm really not. Like, y'all have me on these meetings.
You will, you will, you will, you will take my words, exactly what I told Brandon when I was when I was talking to him last week. I said, I really want these people to feel how pleasant it is, you know, it is talk to Brenda, and he was also laughing. He said that this sounds so good a plan if you put them on a call, I'm pretty sure.
I...
Oh.
Hey.
He's overcome for more confidence. Okay, no worries. Thank you so much. Talking about the optional holidays, and this is the 2026 holiday calendar for the team, nothing new. If I talk with the upcoming Leaders, that is May 25th, Memorial Day. I think that will be all for three of them, all three of them.
Thanks, yes. Wait on.
Okay, yep.
25th, that is Monday, upcoming Monday, that is, yep, Memorial Day.
Yes, that's what, yeah, that's it, yep, yep, yep, yes, yes.
Yeah, great, thank you. And if I talk with the optional holidays, people have chosen their holidays, so at least will be on leave on November, way back. So they all will be, they will take a leave on November, but some time to go so we can talk about that later on. So that's all I have from operational background here by design.
Right.
So this is something, are you aware of AI by design? Have you heard of this? I mean, I'm sure we have been talking about this in every day. So this is a new service that ITBD is providing over there. That new, we are, our main focus is on AI by design right now. And that leads to me to another question. I'm not sure if we have that in tech or not.
Yes.
Are you coming to build it? You or Brandon coming to build it?
I don't know. I'm not. I don't know anyone else's calendars. Yeah, I'm not, but yeah.
Okay, I'll take a follow-up with Brandon. But this is a program that is going to be there if I talk about build it from 3rd or 5th of August, this is going to be there. Venue remains the same. But then, you know, again, the motto is the build for growth, partnership and leadership and intelligence. So primary focus is we are talking about the AI.
how AI is changing the world over there. I'll take a follow with Brandon. I'm pretty sure he's going to be there.
Okay.
Okay, great.
We are good. Brenda using Team GPS, I'm fine with that. Pay forward, daily check-ins with the engineer, that is going to be there. Primarily, my focus, when I say me, ITBD or Manish, everyone's focus is going to be on Hazel. We are not going to do micromanagement, trust me on that part, but we just want her to be more confident and her to reach out to you that, okay.
Yeah.
If she has done something, she should be able to talk about it. If she is stuck somewhere, she should be able to raise her hand. The rest, Derek, he will continue to work on the cradle point upgrades that is his primarily to do. And then Alice, she was continues to work on the security orders, so we are good with that. And then Manish, he is going to be your...
Okay.
Oh.
Your voice from ITBD, whenever you have any any concern, you can reach out to him. Of course, this group now, you know, as well and me, so Manish will continue to assist in the backup validation. That is what he's doing. Rest be a good, so one to do that I have for you. I need to confirm on the Hazel new shift, how soon we can move her in the in that shift.
And second, Alice will be.
Yeah, I'm not expecting this to be overnight with the move. I'm just, I mean, that's where we want to work for. You know, I'm not saying that for the next week or even 2, but I think that's the direction we want to move to if that's
possible for her. That's what we started with. Yeah.
No, no, absolutely.
No, no, absolutely. I think I'll take some time to, you know, check with her, check with, check internally, but even that, you rightly said that is a goal, even we want to move in that direction, so we are good with that. And then Alice, 99.99%, please take my word. She will be in the 8.30 to 5.30 shift.
Okay.
And I'll drop an email as soon as I have some confirmation from my transport team. But my discussion with them was really good, really positive. So by expect some response either by today or mostly by tomorrow, that you know, we are moving out to the 8.30 P.m. shift. The rest we are good.
Anything else from your side, Brenda?
Nope, I think we've covered everything I have.
Great, I really appreciate your time. Thank you so much, Khan. Anything from your side, buddy?
Nope, all good. So Brenda, rest assured, we are on top of this and we'll make sure that if there's any concerns, we will address it and get things back on track.
Okay, that sounds good. And they're not completely off track. I mean, they're just, we just have, we just have some, some U-turns there in the road.
Thank you.
Mhm.
Yeah, yeah, that's a great way to look at it in a turns, and I just want to make sure that we are, you know, moving in the direction that we want.
It.
So.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'm...
Yeah, I'm sure we'll be on the straight away soon.
Yeah, yeah. Thank you, Brenda.
Great, thank you.
Sorry, sorry, Kobe, you were saying something? Thank you so much. Thanks, Priya.
Thank you.
No, no, that's I'm good. Thank you.
Okay, thank you. Talk to you soon. Bye-bye.
Bye.